you're not inclined to run your family
isn't gung ho about it but if you look
at and see no Jeb Bush no chris Christie
no one who you think can raise the money
compete against the democratic nominee
that you'll think about it well I think
Jeb is a an excellent person could be a
a terrific president I think that about
a lot of the people who are running on
the Republican side or who I think will
get in my guess is you're going to see
15 or so people on the stage at the
first debate I don't know who they are
all are going to be interstage you don't
see anybody you think we're getting
among those people we're gonna find
someone who catches fire who ignites the
the interest of the Republican base and
you're going to see someone who can go
on to become president and that's why I
said look I'm not running i'm not
planning and running and I got nothing
new on that story all right you left
that door open a little bit there he
said circumstances could change and then
I went on to say I'm not letting my head
go there where I'm focused is making
sure that we nominate the right person
who cares about the kinds of issues I
care about and and so I'm going to work
to try and encourage us as a party and
as a group of candidates who are running
I want to help them recognize how
important foreign policy is how
important is to deal with our economy it
here at home to create jobs and to deal
with the looming issue of poverty that's
become a greater and greater issue over
these last six years which isn't being
addressed